[Applaus]
so meine Damen und Herren erste Show
2024 und das fängt ja direkt gut an XXL
Bahnstreik Trump Erfolge man möchte das
Jahr jetzt schon wieder umtauschen und
wissen Sie was genau die Einstellung ist
grundfalsch Schluss mit immer nur Angst
und immer nur meckern ein neuer Spirit
ist da am schönsten verkörpert durch die
Demos der letzten Tage rund eine
Millionen Menschen waren allein am
letzten Wochenende auf der Straße nach
den korrektivrecherchen zum Thema AFD
und Remigration ja für die
Demokratie und gegen das Ohnmachtsgefühl
was für schöne Bilder oder und was für
kreative Plakate hier z.B eine Fan des
ersten fC Köln nie wieder Faschismus nie
wieder zweite
Liga ich drücke die Daumen für beides
oder
hier ein ganz neu designtes Logo da sind
sämtliche parteiinhalte mit drin und
zwar völlig unbeschnitten ja ja so die
gemeinsame Botschaft an die AFD lautet
natürlich ihr bestimmt nicht wer
Deutscher ist das macht das Grundgesetz
auch in Zukunft damit wir nicht eines
Tages aufwachen und eine ganz böse
Überraschung erleben guten
Abend um Himmels
willen gut keiner weiß natürlich was
diese Demos am Ende bewirken aber allein
die wütende Reaktion von Herrn höcke war
es doch schon wert das waren bestellte
Massen genau da ist also bei dem
Geheimtreffen in posdam mal kurz die AFD
Maske runtergerutscht man trifft sich
mit Vertretern der neuen Rechten um die
remigration/ Deportation von Millionen
von Menschen zu diskutieren ja war ja so
aber und ja na und in zwanglosem Rahmen
einfach mal drauf los brainstormen wo
ist denn bitte das Problem jetzt diese
angebliche Skandal um ein privates
Treffen Berlin wo sind wir hingekommen
dass man sich nicht mehr privat treffen
kann und über alles reden kann eben wo
sind wir hingekommen also wenn man sich
nicht mal mehr privat treffen kann um
das Volk einzuteilen in reinrassige
Deutsche und in Bürger mit
abschiebeperspektive dann ist das nicht
mehr mein Reich
Land übrigens finden solche Treffen in
Deutschland regelmäßig statt man träumt
gemeinsam von einem ja ethnisch
homogenen
Staatsvolk wo alle einen Opa haben der
Karl Heinz heißt oder so ähnlich ich
weiß nicht ne die AFD ist inzwischen ja
sowas wie der wie der parlamentarische
Arm des
Rechtsextremismus beim Treffen in pozam
hat jedenfalls keiner der Anwesenden dem
Referenten Martin selner widersprochen
dem posterby der rechtsextremen
identitären Bewegung es gibt drei
remigrationszielgruppen es gibt erstens
asulanten es gibt nicht Staatsbürger und
es gibt nicht assimilierte eingebürgerte
Staatsbürger die zu Unrecht eingebürgert
wurden und die vierte Gruppe sind
Österreicher die sich hier ungefragt
einmischen und denen man zurufen möchte
geh
scheißen so in derselben schurkenrunde
hat laut Korrektiv Ulrich Siegmund
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD
SachsenAnhalt gesagt sein Bundesland
müsse für ausländische Restaurants
unattraktiver werden was er im
Nachhinein bestreitet weniger
ausländisches essen was soll man denn
stattdessen futtern wahrscheinlich
deutschen Döner ja ja er gibt's
natürlich klar man nehme kleingehacktes
Eisbein Haut das wabbelige as auf ein
gutes arisches Schwarzbrot Sauerkraut
dabei Spreewaldgurke und natürlich
stadtscharfe Soße ein ordentlicher
Schuss
Eierlikör fertig ist günis original
deutscher Döner
m lecker lecker
ja wohl bekommen
geht alles ja wir merken der letzte
bürgerliche tahnanstrich der AFD bröselt
dahin mehrere AFD Abgeordnete
beschäftigen in ihren Büros sogar
Mitarbeiter der identitären Bewegung und
so sieht das übrigens aus wenn die junge
alternative Bayern darunter zwei
Landtagsabgeordnete mal rein privat in
die Disco
[Musik]
geht Deutschland den deutschen Ausländer
raus wird da gesungen können solche
Leute Herr Baumann Mitglieder der AFD
Jugendorganisation sein ich weiß nicht
die haben da Bier getrunken und alles
mögliche gemacht Deutschland den
deutschen heißt wir haben ein deutsches
Volk das sind alle die den deutschen
Pass haben die die legal zu uns kommen
arbeiten unsere Werte übernehmen Ihre
Kinder ordentlich erziehen sind uns alle
herzlich willkommen ja so ein Theater
ein PAL Lausbuben haben ihr erstes Bier
getrunken so what ne Ausländer raus der
Klassiker unter den Naziparolen und
nicht mal davon wird sich der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der AFD
Bundestagsfraktion öffentlich
distanzieren keine weiteren Fragen die
meinten mit deutschen alle Bürger mit
deutschem Pass ist klar bitte meinten
die wirklich hören wir noch mal rein
Deutschland in deutschen Ausländer raus
wir mein natürlich nicht die mit
deutschem Pass nur Ausländer ohne
schutzberechtigung die cheidung ist uns
echt wichtig nicht W den wir wären
recht verstehe verstehe ja gut dass wir
da noch mal reingehört haben ne dass wir
das klären konnten so und was jetzt
meine Damen und Herren ein AFD
Verbotsverfahren dauert wohl 3 bis 5
Jahre und riecht so kurz vor Wahlen nur
nach Hilflosigkeit das ist schlecht der
grundrechtsentzug für Bernt höcke klingt
verlockend aber eigentlich wollen wir in
einem Staat leben der niemandem
Grundrecht wegnimmt okay die die
Lehrberechtigung als
Geschichtslehrer die könnte man den
Bernt vielleicht mal entziehen als Idee
nur als Idee finde
ich wegen der
Kinder es muss einem nur klar sein dass
das Prädikat rechtsextrem für viele für
viele seinen Schrecken verloren hat in
diesem Land wie schnell man sich bei so
einer Partei doch gewöhnt an offenelebte
Gewaltfantasien wir müssen den
kannickeln in den Parlament den
verdienten Nackenschlag versetzen und
nicht unseren eigenen parteikameraden
jetzt sind sie auch noch gegen Knickel
das ist doch die Kameraden so natürlich
müssen sich alle anderen Parteien fragen
was sie zum Aufstieg dieser Partei
beigetragen haben Idee statt sich an
Demos ranzuhängen könnten ampelpolitiker
ja auch mal versuchen ich weiß nicht für
den Anfang 2 D Wochen ohne Streit zu
regieren in Stillarbeit das wäre die
beste Maßnahme gegen Rechts meine Damen
und Herren und das schließt ja anderes
nicht aus z.B den Entzug der staatlichen
Finanzierung dann hätte die AFD pro Jahr
10 Millionen Euro weniger auf einen
Schlag müssen Sie damit Spenden wieder
reinholen da fehlt mir ein das könnte
doch der der Chef von dieser
großmolkerei spendieren der sich so
gerne mit Alice Weidel trifft in der
Bild steht die korrupten Eliten wollen
deiner lieblingspartei den geldh
zudrehen was beruhig dich erstm und gönn
dir einen schönen Milchreis von
meja von jedem Becher wandern ab sofort
20 Cent in die AFD Parteikasse der Rest
geht an die
reibürgerbewegung Milchreis von Meer
wenn der Kleine höcke kommt alles Meer
oder
was
ja üpenden
ausgleichen wenn dazu kommt ist auch ein
ganz Sch
fen dabei ist ja schon seit 1945
abgelaufen na ja so und um das noch mal
ganz klar zustellen selbstverständlich
meinen viele in der AFD mit Remigration
schon lange auch die von deutschen
Staatsbürgern Höcker hat dazu Zitat
wohltemperierte Grausamkeiten
versprochen und der Spitzenkandidat der
AFD für Europa Maximilian Krah dieser
promovierte Seitenscheitel hier hat
neulich sogar ein Buch drüber
geschrieben darin beschreibt Krah
detailliert seine remigrationspläne auch
prognostisch wie er sagt für die über 15
Millionen deutsche Staatsangehörige sein
Ziel den Erhalt des Volkes damit
Deutschland Deutsch bleibe erersetzt auf
Kooperation setzt er verstehe so 15
Millionen Menschen werden also gegangen
freiwillig sagen wir mal und ich begrüße
Maximilian krass Referentin Gisa Flake
Frau Flake war das denn schlau von ihrem
Chef das so offen in sein Buch zu
schreiben welke Remigration ist do unser
geringstes Problem da bucht man bei ryir
15 Millionen Flüge
Feierabend dieses Land hat ganz andere
Sorgen nachzulesen in Herrn Dr KRAS
Meisterwerk Politik von rechts da
beschreibt dieser küne Vordenker
erschütternd präzise nicht weniger als
die Krise des deutschen Mannes ich habe
eine Krise guck dich doch mal an ich
zitiere eine groeahl von ausgebildeten
sexuell attraktiven und selbstbewussten
Frauen hallo konkurriert um eine kleiner
werdende Zahl von als Alpha
wahrgenommenen Männern ob der sinkende
Testosteronspiegel der Männer der
steigende Anteil der
Übergewichtigen wir sind in schlechten
Zustand und das betrifft natürlich vor
allem das softe
ökoges die letzte Generation hat einfach
zu wenig Testosteron W mit weinlichem
Gesicht sich auf die Straße klebt und
Angst davor hat in 50 Jahren zu sterben
der ist wirklich letzte Generation malte
sren und seine SoJ Boys brauchen
richtiges Leben Sport Wettkampf und
Testosteron ja maltesuren und die Soja
Boys das klingt wie eine ganz schlimme
Band das sind sie auch welke insgesamt
erleben wir weltweit einen signifikanten
Rückgang der Spermienzahl ja auch ihre
Spermien lassen sich hängen die sitzen
da mit ihnen jeden Abend faul von der
Glotze und Schwimmen im Kreis und das
ist das Problem das Deutschland hat
meine Spermien was hat das jetzt mit
links oder rechts zu tun Herr Dr Kra
warnt völlig zurecht vor der Zitat
entmännlichung unserer Gesellschaft
immer mehr Frauen finden keinen
Alphamann und immer mehr Männer bleiben
ich sag das jetzt mal ganz offen
ungebumst genau dagegen hilft rechte
Politik denn Zitat rechte Politik bejaht
echte Männlichkeit und fordert die Räume
in denen sie erlernt und praktiziert
werden kann vom Fußballclub bis zur
schlagenden
Studentenverbindung wo man sich so
gegenseitig mit Säbeln piie ist doch
voll gefährlich mein Gott W sieeh mich
an aus ihnen wird niemals ein deutscher
Baum rechts heißt du bist ein Baum du
hast eine Wurzel du bist verbunden mit
Essen jedes Jahr blühst du neu und du
hast eine Krone die nach oben in den
Himmel
zeigt deine mächge K steil nach oben sie
irrigiert quasi geh
Himmel verzeihung ich habe mich gehen
lassen ist schon okay ist schon okay und
mit dem geistigen dünchis wird man
chefintellektueller bei der AFD ach was
wissen Sie denn sie hätten dabei sein
sollen als Herr Dr Krah neulich den
anderen geistigen Titan der AFD
getroffen hat so viel Testosteron im
selben Raum es müsste eigentlich
verboten sein danke dass du heute da
bist
[Musik]
also du berühst mich in so vielen
Dimensionen danke
[Musik]
mox du berührst mich in so vielen
verschiedenen Dimensionen vergiss es SoJ
Boy schade Gisa Flake meine Damen und
[Applaus]
Herren so meine Damen und Herren
und auch
heute gab es schon wieder bauernproteste
in Deutschland z.B in Berlin spannendes
Phänomen in diesen Tagen achten Sie mal
drauf jeder liebt die Bauern jeder
wirklich es gibt es gibt überhaupt keine
Partei die nicht versucht sich bei den
Bauern anzubiedern warte mal da fällt
mir ein das kann ich doch auch Sekunde
ich bin gleich wieder
da kann ich das Tragen oder kann ich das
Tragen meine Damen und
[Applaus]
Herren ja ah
komm ja alle bieden sich bei den Bauern
an dann mache ich das auch
ja bin tatsächlich aufgewachsen in harse
Winkel wo es eigentlich immer nach Gülle
geroch
und zwar nicht nur bei uns zu Hause
sondern auch draußen ja so aber von
sowas habt ihr Stadtmenschen ja gar
keine Ahnung genau wie der Scholz der
diese Woche die Grüne Woche besucht hat
wo er quasi als Symbol für seine
Agrarpolitik diesen toten Baum gepflanzt
hat ja ja ja der Baum war ursprünglich
grün ist aber bei der Rede von Scholz
eingegangen so sie werden es sicherlich
mitbekommen haben die deutschen Bauern
fordern immer noch die komplette
Rücknahme der subventionsstreichung und
machen weiter ordentlich Druck haben sie
das gesehen wie die neulich in Berlin
den Lindner ausgebuht haben Alter dabe
hat der Mann auf der Bühne alles gegeben
um zu sagen ich bin einer von euch ja
wirklich
man man denkt ja immer der Lindner wä so
elitär eigentlich ist der quasi Landwirt
ich bin neben wiesenfeldern und dem Wald
aufgewachsen ich bin Jäger ich bin schon
fertig wenn ich den Pferdestall einmal
ausgemistet habe deshalb weiß ich was
das für eine Arbeit ist ich bin ich bin
ein einfacher Mann des Volkes denn meine
Frau hat ein
Pferd ja gut immerhin hat der Herr
Lindner da was geerntet als Bauer
nämlich den Spot der wütenden Landwirte
und jetzt achten Sie bitte nur mal auf
den Chef des Bayerischen Bauernverbands
ganz links im Bild so geht subtile
Körpersprache ich bin Vorsitzender einer
Partei die sich seit Jahrzehnten für den
Mittelstand
einsetzt der Luftverkehr leistet einen
Beitrag die Regierung selbst hören Sie
während auf der anderen Seite in unserem
Land Menschen Geld bekommen fürs nichts
tun die Rückerstattung wird in den
nächsten Jahren nur schrittweise
[Applaus]
gebaut fantastisch wirklich ganz
herzlichen Glückwunsch an den Erfinder
des ganzkörper
BU Wahnsinn ja irgendwie gemein dass die
echten Bauern dem Lindner seine neue
Rolle nicht abnehmen dabei sind die
neuen FDP Plakate dazu so toll geworden
kennen Sie die lieber nicht melken als
schlecht melken
z.B plus natürlich lindn Foto aus dem
aktuellen
jungenbauernkalender so Frage wie konnte
es zu diesem Debakel komm da wird ohne
Absprache wirklich ohne Absprache mit
dem Landwirtschaftsminister ein
Sparkonzept hingehudelt die Bauern
werden überproportional belastet es gibt
Gegenwind und die Ampel knickt sofort
ein ja damit auch der letzte merk das
nicht zu Ende gedacht war hä sie mussten
halt kurzfristig 17 Milliarden Euro
mobilisieren
ob jetzt solche runden wo drei Männer
zusammitzen bis zum Morgengrauen die Uhr
läuft ab man ist müde man ist stehen ko
vielleicht ist auch einer krank und man
muss halt irgendwie das mobilisieren ob
das immer zu den allerbesten Ergebnissen
führt kann man sicherlich geteilter
Meinung sein
ähm habe ich das richtig verstanden der
Grund für den aktuellen Bauernkrieg ist
die waren müde na ja wahrscheinlich sah
die entscheidende staatssekretärrunde
kurz vor Weihnachten so aus
so Leute die Geschäfte machen gleich zu
von wem holen wir uns das fehlende Geld
komm wir machen alphabetisch Beruf mit a
Anwälte die hfte des Bundestages sind
Juristen Ausländer kein Beruf vergessen
wir a Beruf mit
Bauern Bingo das ist es doch darauf
Einfass Gülle kriegen die nicht mit auf
dem Land hab ke
internetbei warte
mal dieau nicht die stärkste Lobby von
allen die Ampel auch nur Menschen die
irgendwann nach Hause
wollen eben ja es ist ja so alles nur
Menschen
müde vielleicht war einal krank
gut am Ende geht's natürlich gar nicht
um die en dieselsubvention sondern um
Probleme die viel älter sind älter als
die Ampel Stichwort Höfe sterben das
gibt schon seit den 50er Jahren und zwar
völlig unabhängig davon wer gerade
regiert in Deutschland höfeesterben im
Schnitt machen jedes Jahr
3500 Betriebe dicht nicht zuletzt weil
die größeren bei uns die kleinen
Schlucken und so immer größer werden ist
ganz wichtig für die Debatte Bauer ist
nicht gleich Bauer meine wir denken ja
immer noch an den romantischen Biohof wo
man jedes Schwein mit Namen kennt die
Landwirtschaft ist handgemacht die Tiere
werden noch persönlich angesprochen fein
Musik du wirst
geschlachtet ja ja ja ja aber aber so
schön haben es nicht alle Schweine und
auch nicht alle Landwirte denn
Subventionen werden bei uns immer noch
nach Fläche gezahlt es gibt mächtige
agrarholdings die im Jahr Millionen
kriegen und Kleinbauern die mit ein paar
Hund Euro abgespeist werden deswegen ist
bei manchen der Frust auch mehr als
verständlich bei Milchbauern z.B die
teilweise mit jedem Liter Milch Verlust
machen weil sie den Preis gar nicht
selber festlegen die sind verpflichtet
ihre Milch an bestimmte Großmolkereien
abzugeben und erfahren dann Wochen
später wie viel Geld sie pro Liter
kriegen die Verhandlungsposition die ist
systematisch so dass wir um ehrlich zu
sein gar keine Verhandlungsposition
haben ja kein BWL studiert aber keine
ist eine sehr schlechte
Verhandlungsposition fün Großmolkereien
beherrschen bei uns über 50 des Marktes
das sind im milchbusiness die waren
Zitzen Verdiener ja und so und diese
großen sitzen absurderweise mit den von
ihnen ausgebeuteten Kleinbauern im
selben Bauernverband der weil liegen
seit Jahren die Vorschläge der
sogenannten Borchard Kommission auf dem
Tisch inklusive Subventionen eben nicht
mehr nur nach Fläche sondern auch nach
ökologischen Kriterien warum setzt die
Ampel das nicht einfach um ja weil sie
Schiss haben vor den Bauern klar alle
haben Schiss vor den Bauern warte mal
das ist doch die
Geschäftsidee du bist Krankenpfleger
keinen interessiert dass du mehr Lohn
willst und du fragst dich warum weil du
keinen Trecker hast natürlich warum denn
wohl sonst mein Tipp komm noch heute zu
treckerverleih welke D deine Forderungen
mehr Achtung Profil kriegen
treckerverleih welke denn der Traktor
ist der entscheidende
Faktor
ja
me
besten jetzt aber endlich mal zur
eigentlich schlimmen Nebenwirkung des
ganzen bauernaufstands Bayerns bestes
Comedy Duo bricht gerade auseinander ja
Hubert eiwanger und Markus Söder ja die
Freundschaft ist zu Ende sie wetteifern
um die Gunst der wütenden Bauern Söder
wurde von denen teilweise ausgebut in
den letzten Tagen Hubert wird nur
gefeiert und das ist ja kein Wunder denn
er selber Land wirrd und war neulich und
das jetzt kein Witz an nur einem Tag auf
fünf verschiedenen bauerndemos wie geht
das fragen Sie sich ganz einfach
eiwanger arbeitet inzwischen mit
Doppelgängern wie Putin im Grunde ja
Christian ehing z.B ist heute als
eiwanger Dubel im Einsatz Herr Ering sie
sind aus Düsseldorf die eiwangerrolle
nimmt ihn doch keine Sau ab
was
schwuchsinn eiwanger kann doch im Grunde
jeder du musst einfach sprechen
konsequent alle as gegen OS austauschen
fertig plus sppelhut mehr ist es doch
nicht oder
burm se ja inzwischen beschwert sich die
CSU schon über eiwanger weil als
Minister gar nicht mehr arbeitet und nur
noch demonstriert verstehen sie die CSU
ist jetzt die Stimme der
Vernunft och die hen doch den ohschofen
die ohschlöcher do in München weck der
Söder ist bloß eifersüchtig weil nur der
hupsi weiß was die Bauern hören wollen
nämlich dass die Grünen schuld sind und
zwar an
em die Grünen wollen das wenn sich keine
Räder mehr drehen dann wird kein CO2
mehr ausgestoßen dann werden keine
Lebensmittel mehr transportiert dann
können wir in den Keller runtergehen
können die Mao Bibel lesen und können
auf sterben
warten die grünenollen wir alle sterben
ja der eiwanger soll man vor der eigenen
Stalltür kehren als Wirtschaftsminister
keine Fortschritte beim mobilfunkusbau
in Bayern bei Entbürokratisierung oder
Fachkräftemangel
langweilig Söder ist auch selber schuld
er wollte unbedingt mit eiwanger
regieren und jetzt zeigt der Hubert ihm
halt mal wo der populistenfrosch die
Locken hat bzw wo der Kern im Pudel
steckt und jetzt B ich mal des Pudels K
diesend Regierung gibt zu viel Geld aus
für taugenixe und deshalb ist kein Geld
mehr da für die die Arbeiten bitte er
ist doch der der wo überhaupt nicht mehr
arbeitet es gibt klimakleber die mehr
arbeiten als
der sie kapieren wirklich gar nichts
eiwanger ist der geilste keiner wirklich
keiner kann am rednerbult so dermaßen
aufdrehen wenn der eiwanger Freestyle
dann kastriert sich das Ferkel vor
Begeisterung selber und Gott beschütze
unseren frontz Beckenbauer und ich sage
wir brauchen wieder mehr Beckenbauer und
weniger Scholz in
Deutschland
Beckenbauer was redet der ja da staunt
er der doof Stadtmensch um auf solche
genialen Sätze zu kommen muss man
nämlich jahrelang Agrardiesel eingeatmet
haben so oh scheiße nee da kommt einer
von Söders schlechten Doppelgängern hau
ob du
Amateur huberting meine Damen und Herren
vielen
[Applaus]
Dank ha die Leute ich wollte euch nur um
ein kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's
gut na los na los du scheißpferd hey